you want to see the world in one night  come with me an unprecedented global  television event Suns coming up here in  Africa we've been up for a couple hours  we're heading out onto the plains to  catch some of the action of the  migration  we're exploring we have no idea what  we're gonna bump into the world's  greatest wildlife cinematographers and  explorers we're headed up to see the  ultimate breaking we'll capture stunning  wildlife in real-time  [Applause]  [Music]  in dozens of locations across six  continents you can't even believe how  far this place is from anywhere look  around it's incredibly using  cutting-edge technology  [Music]  experience the adventure of a lifetime  [Applause]  there's a lot of action here the three  cubs are underneath our car that was one  of the most incredible displays of power  ever seen  Lud posted by Jane Lynch and Phil  Keoghan anything can happen  earth live Sunday July 9th at 8:00  Eastern on National Geographic